clark county school board held an  evaluation of superintendent dr jesus  jarrah today the board wants to conduct  a hostile work environment investigation  before his contract is up in january  they voiced their frustrations in what  they believe needs to change if he is  reinstated  it's like at what point  do we stop bringing items that spotlight  and put to the public once again  the personal issues that the board has  between the board members and when do we  start bringing items that actually will  improve  the climate and culture of the district  now they did vote on having  superintendent dr jarrah work with  trustee garcia morales to continue his  culture evaluation the vote passed 4-3